Alors, ça en est où ?
C'est bon ? Tu as un visu sur eux ?
Ne me touche pas !
C'est bon, ils sont en train de s'embrouiller, là.
OK.
Alors fonce, mon gars.
Tu me lâches.
Laisse-moi !
- Je m'en bats les couilles.
- Ne me touche pas !
- Je m'en fous.
Hé!
Ne me touche pas !
Lâche-la.
Tu es qui, toi ?
Ah ouais, je suis un ouf.
J'avoue, vous n'allez rien capter
si je n'explique pas qui je suis.
Bon, moi, c'est Lassana,
a.k.a. Vaudou.
En gros, je suis un genre de superhéros.
Enfin, plus ou moins, quoi.
Après, je vous calme tout de suite.
Je ne vole pas, je n'ai pas
de force surhumaine, tout ça.
Moi, mon pouvoir, c'est que je rêve d'agression
ou de crime un jour avant que ça se produise.
Je ne sais pas trop d'où ça sort,
mais je sais que dans ma famille,
il y a toujours eu des gens
qui rêvent de choses qui vont arriver.
Mais bon, je n'y croyais pas vraiment
jusqu'à ce que je rêve de la mort de mon propre père.
Il était chauffeur de taxi et je suis sûr
que j'aurais pu faire quelque chose.
Aujourd'hui, bah je m'en veux carrément.
Je sais que le héros qui perd quelqu'un
de proche, c'est méga cliché, mais accrochez-vous
parce que j'ai plus cliché que ça.
Et quand je vous dis ça,
je vous parle de mon meilleur ami Farès.
Non, lui, il croit vraiment qu'on est dans un film
et je crois qu'il kiffe ça, en vrai.
Mais bon, en vérité,
sans lui, je n'arriverais à rien.
C'est quand même un putain de fardeau ce pouvoir,
parce qu'après chaque rêve,
on doit décortiquer ce que j'ai vu et agir vite.
Ah !
Il y a un truc que je n'ai pas dit aussi.
C'est qu'à chaque fois que j'ai une vision,
je prends feu vite fait,
c'est un peu chiant aussi.
Mais bon, heureusement,
ce n'est pas tous les jours.
Et sinon bah, comme tous les superhéros,
il y a un méchant dans mon histoire.
Je vous présente Soldat.
C'est le roi des enculés.
La plupart des gens que je dois sauver,
c'est dû à ses magouilles de merde, là,
parce qu'il exploite les petits du quartier
et j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'il n'a pas de cœur.
Putain, je le déteste.
Bah voilà, vous savez tout.
Merde, je suis con.
Je ne vous ai même pas expliqué
ce que je fous là.
En gros, une nuit avant, bah j'ai une vision de ce mec
frappant sa copine d'une manière assez violente,
au point qu'elle finissait dans le coma
et grâce à Farès,
on a trouvé l'immeuble.
Et en passant par le toit,
j'ai pu atteindre leur balcon.
Après, vu que c'était fermé,
bah, j'ai attendu, quoi.
Mais maintenant, je peux intervenir.
Mais...
toi, tu n'es pas le mec là
qui filme les meufs et qui met sur Internet, toi ?
Attends, attends…
Non, non, non, je t'arrête tout de suite.
Ce n'est pas moi.
Si, si, si, c'est toi !
Hé, frère, tu confonds.
Mais gros, je ne vais pas te laisser
frapper une meuf, quand même.
Parce que je ne sais pas
me défendre toute seul, genre ?
Non, je n'ai pas dit ça, mais…
Tu ne peux pas comprendre,
il va aller trop loin, là.
Comment ça je vais aller trop loin ?
Mais c'est quoi cette histoire ?
Et déjà, c'est qui lui ?
Tu ramènes des mecs chelou
pour m'afficher.
Hé, je ne traîne plus avec toi. Tu sais quoi ? Fin.
Bah casse-toi, alors !
Casse-toi !
Casse les couilles.
C'est ça. Bonne soirée ! Ciao !
Hé, Farès, la situation est sous contrôle.
Je crois que c'est réglé, mon pote.
De quoi "c'est réglé" ?
C'est bon, il est parti ?
Non, non, je ne parle pas avec…
Je parle à mon assistant, en fait.
Ah, tu as un assistant et tout ?
Ah, tu es un vrai superhéros, toi, en fait.
- Attends, mais je ne suis pas ton assistant !
- Bah ouais.
Attends, attends, c'est de l'ironie, là ?
Sans blague.
Je suis ton associé !
Pas "assistant".
Attends, mais j'ai l'impression
que tu savais ce qui allait se passer avant.
Je suis folle ?
Non, tu n'es pas folle.
Mais bon, laisse tomber, en vrai,
je ne peux pas te révéler mes secrets.
Ah wesh, tu y crois vraiment, en fait.
Non, bref, oublie.
Tu veux que j'appelle la police ?
Parce qu'on sait jamais s'il revient
et que je ne suis pas là…
Pour le coup, les superhéros ne font pas ça.
Bah en fait, je t'explique.
En vrai, moi, je viens, j'interviens, je fais en sorte
que ça n'aille pas plus loin, mais bon.
Après, ça ne tient pas qu'à moi.
C'est à toi d'appeler la police.
C'est leur métier, pas le mien, tu vois.
Enfin...
comme ça, c'est plus simple.
Et c'est tout ?
Ouais, ouais, je crois.
OK, bah tu peux rentrer chez toi.
Bonne idée.
Bon bah, bon courage.
Fais attention à toi.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Ah.
Je crois que je vais passer par la porte.
C'est mieux.
Ouais.
Bon courage.
Bon, frérot, tu as fini ?
Non, laisse tomber, là,
je suis avec une vieille dame qui s'est endormie, là.
Je dois la raccompagner dans le 77, sa mère.
Vas-y, rentre sans moi.
Vas-y, vas-y, on s'en tape. Vas-y.
Par contre, je ne dors pas.
Ah.
Il y a un mec, il y a un mec, tire dessus.
Tu fais quoi, toi, encore ?
Vas-y, va dormir.
Vas-y, vas-y.
Les mecs, je dois quitter.
Vas-y, Soldat, détale !
Vas-y, cours, Soldat, cours !
Donc tu as eu deux visions en deux jours.
Ça ne t'est jamais arrivé, ça ?
Non.
Je suis sûr que ça veut dire un truc.
Déjà, on sait que c'est dehors
et de ce que tu as vu,
il y a des marques blanches au sol.
Ça peut être un parking, un truc du genre.
Ouais.
Et en plus de ça, tu as vu trois gars.
Il va falloir être très malin, mec,
parce que même si tu tapes bien,
tu ne vas pas coucher trois mecs à toi tout seul.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Ouais, mais en vrai,
pourquoi on devrait le sauver ?
Tu es sérieux, là ?
Bah ouais, je suis sérieux,
si ça se trouve, c'est son karma, c'est tout.
Le mec, c'est le roi des enculés.
Si ça se trouve, il mérite
qu'on le remette à sa place. Fin.
Lass, ce n'est pas à nous de réfléchir à ça.
Si tu peux sauver la personne, tu dois le faire.
C'est tout.
Sinon tu es autant une merde que lui.
Et toi, tu n'es pas une merde.
Tu es le héros de l'histoire.
Et moi, je suis le pote du héros,
super intelligent et beau gosse.
Attends, normalement, le pote du héros,
il n'est pas spécialement beau gosse,
il est con et en plus, il fait des blagues.
Des fois, il n'est même pas marrant.
Ah ouais ?
Ouais.
Et le héros, il n'est pas
censé vivre chez ses parents ?
Prendre des 4-0 à FIFA
et se faire tèj par la meuf qu'il aime ?
Hein ?
C'est grave, quand même.
Tu lui envoies des messages et elle ne répond pas.
"Tu fais quoi, bébé ?"
Vu.
"Tu dors ?"
"Je ne sais pas si tu as vu
mes deux derniers messages."
Vu. Toujours vu.
Frère, appelle-la "Vu" sur ton répertoire.
C'est grave, quand même.
Toi, t'es marrant, là ?
Excuse-moi.
Je suis allé un peu loin, là, j'avoue.
Tu sais quoi ?
Toi, tu as de la chance, t'es mon frérot.
Je t'aurais fait une dinguerie depuis.
Tu es au courant ou pas ?
Non, je ne suis pas au courant.
Je ne pense pas parce que
physiquement, tu n'es pas ouf.
Ah ouais ?
Ouais, physiquement parlant,
tu n'es pas…
- Vas-y, viens, on s'envoie tout de suite, là.
- Tu n'es pas ouf.
Bah, il n'y a pas de souci.
Je termine juste mon petit que-gré,
frérot, et après, je t'attrape.
Tu as toujours des prétextes, toi.
- C'est un truc de ouf.
- Ah non, non, mais c'est vrai !
Tu as peur.
Non, c'est de l'appétit.
- Je suis un mec qui a de l'appétit.
- OK, d'accord. Ouais, vas-y, arrête de raconter ta life.
Bref, c'est quoi le plan, là,
associé super intelligent et beau gosse ?
Bah déjà,
on connaît la future victime, pour une fois.
Ouais.
Donc je pense
qu'il faut aller voir Soldat, tout simplement.
Quoi ?
Attends, tu sais que mes sauvetages
ne marchent que si j'interviens juste avant.
Et en plus, dans ma vision,
il faisait nuit donc c'est impossible.
Je ne te dis pas d'aller le voir pour le sauver,
mais peut-être qu'on peut essayer
de savoir où il sera ce soir-là, justement.
Vas-y.
OK, on peut tenter ça.
Parfait.
C'est parti.
Je viens avec toi parce que je sens
que tu vas le rendre fou.
Puis, tu n'es pas très fort physiquement.
Vas-y, vas-y, viens.
Arrête de rendre ouf.
Oh ouais, ouais, ouais !
- Dragon Ball, c'est comment ?
- Salut, les gars, ça va ou quoi ?
Tu vas bien ?
Ça va ou quoi ?
Hé ! Hé, mon gars !
Dragon Ball !
Bien frérôt ? C'est comment ?
Appelle-nous par nos prénoms, aussi.
Pourquoi ?
Tu n'aimes plus les mangas ?
Si, si, on adore ça.
Bah alors,
pourquoi tu casses les couilles, toi ?
Dragon Ball, c'est flatteur, non ?
Oui et non puisque les Dragon Ball à la base,
ce ne sont pas des personnages,
c'est juste des boules de cristal, rien de plus.
Bon après, c'est vrai
qu'elles permettent d'invoquer Shenron,
un dragon qui permet d'exaucer…
Hé, là, je me suis endormi
pendant que tu parles, cousin.
Hé, vas-y, tu sais quoi ? J'ai rendez-vous.
Vas-y, taillez.
Ce soir, tu es à la cité ?
Pourquoi tu me demandes ça, toi ?
On veut bosser pour toi,
faire tourner le terrain.
Attends, Farès, c'est entre lui et moi.
Quoi ?
Si je te dis qu'on a une recette
pour faire de la meth à 99 %,
tu en dis quoi ?
Je n'en dis rien. Hé, arrêtez.
Hé les gars, arrêtez de croire
que vous vivez dans une série là.
Là, on est dans la vraie vie.
Alors un conseil,
cassez-vous avant que je vous casse la bouche.
Hé, Lass !
Dis à ton frère de m'appeler, s'il te plaît !
Ouais, ouais.
Putain, j'ai le seum !
Non mais ouais, 99 %, ce n'est pas réaliste.
J'aurais dû dire moins.
Je le savais.
Mais tu as vu comment il nous parle, là?
Ce n'est pas toi, c'est moi.
96 à la rigueur, ça aurait pu passer,
mais 99 c'est trop.
Je sais.
Tranquille, on va trouver une solution.
Une solution de quoi ?
Il veut faire quoi
avec mon petit frère, cet enculé ?
Chut.
Quoi ?
J'ai laissé un de mes Airpods à côté d'eux.
On va pouvoir entendre
leur rendez-vous important.
Quoi ?
Frère, regarde sur Internet, tu verras.
Tu veux nous faire quoi encore là ?
C'est quoi le délire ?
Attends, attends, il parle, là.
Apparemment,
ils se sont fait livrer des motocross.
Wesh il a 16 ans ou quoi ?
Justement, il veut les offrir
à des tit-peu, un truc du genre.
Putain, merde, je ne les entends plus.
Ils s'éloignent.
Je crois qu'ils sont montés dans une voiture.
Ils vont sûrement récupérer les motocross.
Frère, il ne faut pas qu'on lâche l'enquête.
Motocross, c'est le parking.
C'est peut-être ça la piste la plus probable.
Hé, frère, frère, c'est bon, là.
À ton avis, pourquoi il offre des cross aux petits ?
Il les exploite, gros.
Vas-y, dis-moi combien ont arrêté
l'école à cause de lui?
Mais à quel moment je t'ai dit
que c'était bien, ça ?
Tu crois que les trois mecs qui vont lui casser
la gueule tout à l'heure, ils sont mieux que lui ?
D'ailleurs, il faut vraiment être
une grande pute pour frapper un mec à trois.
Farès, tu sais quoi ?
Oublie.
Oublie ton plan de je ne sais pas quoi, là.
Je ne le fais pas, c'est mort.
Mais Lass, on est les gentils, nous.
On sauve les gens.
"On" ?
Pourtant c'est moi qui prends
tous les risques à chaque fois.
Ah c'est comme ça ?
Ouais, c'est comme ça.
Hé, frère, on dirait que ça t'amuse tout ça, là.
Ce n'est pas toi qui rêve
tous les jours de trucs de merde
et qui te réveilles
avec toute la pression du monde.
Non, ce n'est pas moi.
Pourtant ça n'empêche pas
que je fasse tout pour t'aider.
Bah écoute, là, si tu veux m'aider,
arrête de me casser les couilles avec Soldat.
C'est bon, je ne le fais pas.
OK.
Le message est passé.
C'est bon, je peux sortir maintenant ?
C'est mort, tu ne sors pas.
Mais maman, elle avait dit que…
Je m'en fous.
Tu ne comprends pas ou quoi ?
C'est dangereux dehors, là, tu ne sors pas.
Tu sais quoi ? Vas-y, prends FIFA,
va jouer au salon. Ne rends pas ouf.
Vas-y, vas-y, fais vite.
Bien ouej.
Mais Lass, on est les gentils, nous.
On sauve les gens.
Pourtant c'est moi qui prends
tous les risques à chaque fois.
T'essaies de jouer au con avec moi ?
Si tu peux sauver la personne,
tu dois le faire faire.
C'est tout.
Sinon, tu es autant une merde que lui.
Bonsoir. Farès ?
- Oui, bonjour.
- C'est ça ?
C'est ça.
- Allez-y, installez-vous.
- Bonjour.
Merci beaucoup.
Voilà, mettez-vous à l'aise.
Merci.
Ah, j'entends un petit accent, là !
Ouais.
Ça vient d'où ça ?
Espagne.
Espagne !
- C'est sympa.
- Oui.
Ça va, vous parlez bien pour une Espagnole.
Ah bah merci.
J'ai appris en regardant des séries et des films.
Ah ouais ?
Oui.
C'est incroyable !
Après, en même temps, moi aussi,
c'est vrai que j'apprends un peu le japonais,
mais avec les mangas.
C'est un peu pareil.
Bah ouais.
Bah si tu apprends vite,
il faut que tu regardes des séries espagnoles,
c'est proche du français.
Ouais, après, vos séries,
je les trouve un peu claquées quand même.
"Claquées", ça veut dire quoi ?
"Claquées", ça veut dire que ça pue du cul.
C'est de la merde, quoi, c'est ça.
C'est de la grosse merde.
Comment expliquer ? De la "mierda".
Ouais.
Allô ?
Ouais, Farès.
Hé c'est bon, je sais.
Les marquages au sol, ce n'était
pas un parking, c'était au collège, en fait.
Et c'est là-bas que Soldat,
il va se faire soulever.
Cool mais encore ?
Ah ouais.
Excuse pour tout à l'heure, frérot.
Mais encore ?
Je ne sais pas, moi.
Tu es le meilleur associé
qu'un héros puisse rêver.
Voilà, là ça me plaît.
Là, j'aime bien.
Je ne sais pas moi, allez, vas-y,
le Iron Man de la Kabylie, tu es content, maintenant ?
Ah, là tu es mon frérot, là.
Là, on s'entend bien, là.
C'est bon, je viens tout de suite. J'arrive.
Quand vous dites: "tout de suite",
c'est après m'avoir déposée à destination ?
Il est où ton putain de téléphone ?
Tu l'as caché où ?
Hein ?
Hé !
Mais "que haces" ?
Mais vous allez où ? Ce n'est pas par là !
Non, non.
Il y a un truc qu'il faut que je vous montre.
Calme-toi !
Oh, vous faites quoi, là ?
Allez circulez, Monsieur, circulez.
Hé, ils ont essayé de rouler
sur les petits, ces fils de pute.
J'ai tout filmé !
- Ta gueule, je te dis !
- J'ai tout filmé !
J'ai tout filmé !
Vous jouez à quoi, là ?
Il n'a même pas d'arme, rien du tout,
vous continuez à le frapper.
Ils ont le seum, mon frère !
Tu vas la fermer ta gueule.
Tu veux quoi ?
Tu veux faire le beau avec moi, c'est ça ?
Vas-y, lâchez-le !
Je m'en bats les couilles, frère.
Ils peuvent me tuer.
Il ne faut pas tuer des petits.
Calme-toi !
Il ne faut pas tuer les petits.
Lass... Qu'est-ce que tu peux faire ?
Donne-moi le portable, petit enculé.
Ils sont trois.
Dans les histoires de superhéros,
c'est tellement facile de savoir
qui sont les méchants et qui sont les gentils.
Et dans la vraie vie,
ce n'est pas aussi simple.
J'étais complètement perdu, mais...
Qu'est-ce que tu fais, là?
Bouge pas !
Vous pensiez que j'étais foutu aussi ?
Bah non
parce que Farès, encore lui,
a réussi à prévenir toute la cité.
Sans parler de la touriste espagnole
qui n'était pas là pour blaguer.
Bref, du coup, les condés n'ont
pas eu d'autre choix que de partir
et là, les gens ont commencé à m'acclamer.
J'ai vraiment eu l'impression d'être un héros.
Mais finalement,
je me suis surtout rendu compte que j'avais passé
trop de temps à essayer d'être un bon superhéros,
et pas assez de temps à être un bon être humain.